getting thrown to the ground is not
everyone's idea of fun but shogo uazumi
loves it the Japanese wrestler left
Tokyo last year to base himself in chess
the third largest city in Senegal where
a version of wrestling called Lam is the
national sport
blending physical combat with acrobatics
Victory is marked by an opponent's back
hitting the floor
every time I practice I feel myself
getting stronger bit by bit so I feel a
lot of joy and growth I'm reflecting on
my weak points and training hard every
day to improve my skills so that I can
win the fight
while shogo is a student of senegalese
wrestling he's also a teacher of the
Olympic style Greco-Roman skills he's
more familiar with having competed at a
national level in Japan he's opened an
academy preparing three dozen athletes
for the Youth Olympics which Senegal
will host in 2026.
he came and integrated easily sometimes
it feels like we've known him for many
years he's part of us and we're part of
him
shogo first visited Senegal in 2017
during a trip with Japan's Aid agency
and was struck by how much it reminded
him of home
in Senegal as in Japan we have a culture
of hospitality which in Japan is called
ometanashi but in Senegal it's called
taranga Senegalese people live together
with their families and they all support
each other that's my kind of culture
29 year old shogo doesn't earn a lot of
money but he lives in a community of
wrestlers who support his work
they include his close friend Czech
bariam who he met on his previous trip
to the country
I told him that I would help him
whatever it cost him because he came to
my country to develop the sport for our
Nationals without being paid whatever he
wants to do and must accompany him
it may not be lucrative but their hard
work is getting results it's a national
competition last month in front of
hundreds of people one of their students
won a silver medal encouraging signs
with the youth Olympics just three years
away
David Stokes Al Jazeera yeah